el régimen de Ortega habla de
deportación pero pues estas personas son
nicaragüenses les quitaron su
nacionalidad Cómo se explica esta figura
podemos afirmar que es otra violación a
los derechos de estas personas
evidentemente es una violación que
continúa con los crímenes de lesa
humanidad que empezaron en 2018 estas
personas habían sufrido
del despojo de sus derechos
fundamentales y habían sufrido la
persecución por parte del gobierno de
Nicaragua leyes hechas a la medida de la
de la oposición nicaragüense desde el
año
2019 y ahora lo que vemos es esta figura
de El destierro en Nicaragua no existe
en el código penal la figura del
destierro sin embargo hoy fue
fue realizada al margen de cualquier
legalidad De hecho también ellos fueron
impedidos de los Derechos políticos y
los derechos ciudadanos
inhabilitados para siempre sin embargo
lo habíamos dicho desde nuestra
organización desde Cali que el gobierno
está regresando a tiempos tan lejanos
como la colonia al imponer este tipo de
penas como la el destierro y la
inhabilitación perpetua para ejercer
derechos ciudadanos o políticos Bueno
ese trato Pues de una decisión sin
precedentes Pero podemos esperar que el
gobierno siga desterrando a otros presos
Sí esta es una práctica que no es nueva
en Nicaragua ya en otras ocasiones hay
personas que no dejaron
entrar hay aproximadamente unos
ocho religiosos y entre ellos un rector
de un importante universidad en
Nicaragua la universidad centroamericana
Que no dejaron entrar un defensor de
derecho humanos que ahora está radicado
en Estados Unidos es una práctica que ya
venía realizando el gobierno Incluso el
presidente Ortega desterró al esposo de
su hijastra soy la América Narváez lo
desterró verdad y también la desterró a
ella es una práctica que no es nueva en
el gobierno de Nicaragua Lo que sí es
nuevo es el hecho de la quita de la
nacionalidad eso no se había visto es
nuevo y por eso advertimos el día de
ayer desde Cali con sede en Argentina
que es una Nueva Ola y una nueva
práctica de violación de Derechos
Humanos que va a continuar con el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony dublín que calificó la medida
como una puerta un futuro diálogo están
dadas las condiciones para que esto sea
así
depende de con quién se vaya a realizar
el diálogo y la voluntad que tenga el
gobierno de Nicaragua porque
Generalmente Bueno hoy a las cuatro de
la tarde hora de Nicaragua el presidente
Ortega va a hablar seguramente respecto
de esta de este desplazamiento forzado
que constituye un crimen de lesa
humanidad de los tantos crímenes de leso
humanidad que se cometen desde 2018 Yo
pienso que por un lado esperado a gran
parte de la de esas figuras opositoras
que podrían realizar o que podrían estar
habilitadas para estar sentadas en
diálogo y creo que por parte del
gobierno de Nicaragua no habría voluntad